hey astronauts looks like you've just
grown something sweet your hydroponic
garden oh it's just lettuce for the
first time astronauts ate a few red
romaine lettuce leaves they've grown
aboard the International Space Station
haha yeah it wasn't the first time
plants have been grown in space but it
was a giant leap for fresh edible food
in orbit the space salad could be a key
to future manned missions to Mars or
even space colonies and its technology
may find wider use on earth for growing
plants indoors for 33 days the lettuce
grew bathed in red blue and green LED
lights which are highly efficient but
don't make the plants very
mouth-watering but as humans consider
spending more and more time in space
nASA says that gardening may be good for
both nutrition and for crew recreation
and well-being after all it's a long
trip to Mars man